en los dos vídeos pasados estábamos
viendo que simplemente utilizar la
capitalización de mercado puede ser un
poco engañoso cuando tienes compañías
que tienen un montón de apalancamiento o
bien que tienen un montón de deuda por
ejemplo si esto de aquí es el activo de
una compañía y tienen digamos esta
cantidad de deuda y esta cantidad de
capital
y no sé supongamos que además tienen un
poco de efectivo excedente lo voy a
poner acá arriba a la izquierda efectivo
que no se necesita para operar el
negocio esto de acá es efectivo
excedente digo a veces se necesita un
poco de efectivo y la gente a veces no
hace la distinción ponen todo el
efectivo pero lo que realmente queremos
hacer es separar el valor de la empresa
del valor en mercado de capital o del
valor de la deuda déjame escribir eso
para no confundirme entonces esto de acá
es el valor del negocio el valor
empresarial
efe acá está la deuda
deuda el pasivo y acá abajo tenemos el
capital
ahora nada más como un pequeño no
digamos detalle técnico no te preocupes
mucho si te confunde este algo entonces
cuando te escribo el valor empresarial
es el valor del negocio es como el
activo operativo menos el pasivo
operativo es literalmente o sea si
tuvieras digamos en los vídeos pasados
que comprar la taquería cuánto tendrías
que pagar en total para ser dueño de la
taquería es lo que estamos intentando
determinar aquí cuando hablamos del
valor empresarial ahora vimos en los
vídeos pasados cómo calcularlo no va a
hacer daño repasarlo de hecho es uno de
los cálculos menos intuitivos la primera
vez que lo ves entonces vamos a repasar
lo entonces la primera cosa que hay que
determinar es el valor del mercado de
este capital el valor del libro es muy
fácil simplemente ver la hoja de balance
y ahí viene verdad hay un numerito y es
lo que vale capital según lo que los
contadores dicen pero pues ahorita lo
que queremos es el valor del mercado
entonces para determinar lo hay que ver
el precio por acción y multiplicarlo por
la cantidad de acciones déjame ponerlo
aquí la capitalización de mercado es
igual al precio al precio por acción
por la cantidad de acciones
y esto de acá es el valor del mercado de
este capital ahora a partir de este
diagrama reduciremos la formulita vamos
a escribirla el valor empresarial más el
efectivo el efectivo no operativo verdad
o bien inversiones o inversiones
líquidas como quieras llamarlas esta
suma de aquí es igual a la deuda
deuda
más y aquí en vez de ponerle capital le
voy a poner capitalización de mercado
porque queremos el valor en el mercado
de la empresa verdad este precio es
según el mercado y queremos el valor de
empresa según el mercado entonces
queremos el valor de la empresa pero lo
que dice que vale el mercado entonces en
vez de poner capital le pongo
capitalización de mercado porque es lo
que nos interesa de mercado el valor del
mercado del capital
entonces conocemos capitalización de
mercado la deuda y el efectivo los
podemos encontrar en la hoja de balance
ahora restando efectivo de ambos lados
obtenemos que el valor empresarial es
igual
aa
no voy a poner así voy a poner primero
la capitalización de mercado de mercado
más la deuda
- el efectivo simplemente estamos
restando efectivo de ambos lados verdad
menos efectivo así que por ejemplo si
tuviéramos una acción que se está
cotizando en la bolsa mexicana de
valores digamos que su precio es de 10
pesos que hay un millón de esas acciones
acciones es un millón que su compañía
tiene digamos en deuda deuda 50 millones
de pesos 50 millones y que tiene un
excedente de efectivo efectivo de 5
millones entonces cuánto sería su valor
empresarial pues lo primero que tenemos
que hacer es determinar la
capitalización de mercado es 10 pesos
por un millón entonces sería 10 millones
eso de ahí es la capitalización de
mercado hay que sumar la deuda más 50
millones de pesos y una vez más en el
vídeo pasado dije que es muy anti
intuitivo porque estamos encontrando un
valor pero estamos sumando la deuda la
explicación es que si alguien quisiera
comprar toda la taquería así sin nada de
deuda verdad entonces tendría que
comprar
la deuda de aquí tendría que pagarle al
banco tendría que pagarle a los
accionistas y luego podría obtener una
devolución verdad para estos dos obtiene
una devolución por efectivo y entonces
ya tendría todo el activo operativo va
entonces aquí abajo esto de aquí es el
capital y esto ya que es la deuda y
tenemos que restar el efectivo
así el valor empresarial es 65 que sería
55 millones de pesos muy bien hasta
ahorita sólo es un repaso del vídeo de
valor empresarial ahora la pregunta es
ya que lo determinamos como vemos si es
un valor justo para la empresa bueno
cuando teníamos capitalización de
mercado la compara vamos con ganancias
verdad precio por ganancias el
coeficiente p
aquí es por acción es precio por acción
entre ganancias por acción pero también
lo podemos pensar de la siguiente manera
como capitalización de mercado el precio
en mercado del capital entre el ingreso
neto de la compañía para verificarlo por
ti mismo multiplica numerador y
denominador por el número de acciones y
queda capitalización de mercado entre
ingreso neto perdón aquí no es ganancias
es ganancias por acción bueno esta era
una manera de medir la eficiencia y pues
sería bien para comparar dos compañías a
menos que tuvieran estructuras de
capital muy distintas pero si tenemos
valor empresarial entre que tenemos que
dividir o sea valor empresarial que
pondríamos aquí abajo en el denominador
bueno en el vídeo pasado había empezado
a decir que si veíamos el valor
empresarial estábamos viendo las
ganancias que están saliendo de la
empresa de las operaciones empresariales
de este activo de acá en el primer
primer vídeo acerca de estado de
resultados de hecho déjame hacer un
estado de resultados pongamos que
ingreso por ventas era de 100 de 100 mil
pesos vamos a poner que el costo de
bienes vendidos no se digamos de 50
pesos voy a ponerle menos 50 no sabes
qué mejor te voy a mostrar otra
convención uno de ustedes me comentó de
manera muy acertada que hay una comisión
que se usa muchísimo entre los
contadores y los analistas financieros
que es usar paréntesis para poner
números negativos entonces menos 50
entonces a ver aquí tendríamos de
utilidad bruta utilidad bruta sería 50 y
ahorita vamos a hacer algo interesante
vamos a ponerle que la depreciación y
amortización no está incluida aquí
arriba si te confunden estas palabras te
recomiendo ver los vídeos acerca de esos
términos pero toda la depreciación y
amortización va a suceder después
entonces déjame poner primero un poco de
costos de ventas generales y
administrativos de ventas generales y
administrativos digamos que es un gasto
no sé de 10 mil pesos aquí le voy a
poner 10
y supongamos que si hay un poco de
depreciación de amortización que voy a
poner aquí aparte de la depreciación y
amortización en los vídeos pasados había
agrupado estos gastos verdad y casi
siempre lo vas a ver así en los estados
de resultados
de hecho tendrías que ver el estado de
flujos de efectivo para ver de ella lo
voy a hacer en otro vídeo pero ahorita
supongamos que si está separado porque a
veces pasa así supongamos que es un
gasto de 5 de 5 mil pesos va
y luego a ver aquí tendríamos la
utilidad operativa utilidad operativa
cuánto nos queda para ver es 50 menos 10
menos 5 es 35 35 mil pesos hay algunas
otras cosas abajo verdad como el interés
e impuestos dejar de poner los que
podríamos poner el ingreso no operativo
pero bueno deja de poner interés interés
digamos que son cinco mil pesos
y ésta es lo que nos importa de modo que
el ingreso antes de impuestos estamos
pensando que el efectivo está en el
colchón entonces no genera nada y nos
queda 30.000 pesos de ingreso antes de
impuestos 30 mil sin creo que ya se está
amontonando mucho lo que estoy
escribiendo pero bueno ahora pongamos
que es un tercio de impuestos o sea diez
mil
y luego tenemos ganancias
ganancias 30 menos 10 veces 20 en 20 mil
pesos ok entonces lo que sugerí en este
vídeo es que aparte de este estado de
resultados depende únicamente de este
cachito de acá del valor empresarial del
activo operativo pues este de aquí bueno
pues todo lo que está de interés para
abajo depende de la deuda el interés
pues porque depende la deuda y los
impuestos porque el interés lo puedes
deducir entonces pues todo lo de aquí
abajo déjame lo pongo en un bloque todo
esto de acá depende de la estructura de
capital
entonces si nada más quisieras ver que
genera el valor empresarial pues está
generando la utilidad operativa está
generando esto de acá ahora con base de
esta observación pues lo que yo sugerí y
es que un muy buen coeficiente aunque no
es tradicional bueno a lo mejor si es
tradicional pero más bien no lo escucha
es muy seguido es que un buen
coeficiente es valor empresarial /
utilidad operativa utilidad operativa
ok este de aquí yo sugiero que es un muy
buen coeficiente que muchas veces
simplemente es el retorno sobre activo
pero en el inverso de retorno sobre
activos como lo definí en el primer
vídeo recuerda que hay varias
definiciones sobre retorno sobre los
activos verdad presencialmente está
diciendo por cada peso utilidad
operativa cuánto estás pagando por la
empresa según yo esa es una muy buena
métrica en fin pero el coeficiente que
vas a ver más seguido es valor
empresarial dividido entre evita si
obtienes un trabajo como un analista
financiero en alguna compañía vas a
tener que calcular muchísimo esto de acá
y también vas a tener que decir cosas
inteligentes acerca de él claro antes de
poder decir cosas inteligentes de levita
o de cualquier cosa pues es bueno saber
a qué se refiere
para empezar el acrónimo es ganancias
antes de intereses impuestos
depreciación y amortización
entonces vamos a ver el estado de
resultados es ganancias verdad antes de
interés de impuestos depreciación y
amortización esto de acá entonces es
antes de todo esto de aquí vamos a
comparar eso con algo que ya vimos antes
por un lado esta vida
y por otro lado tenemos evita
evites ganancias antes de intereses e
impuestos entonces ebit es ganancia es
verdad que tenemos que sumar impuestos e
intereses y estamos en utilidad
operativa en ella lo mencioné antes
verdad pero la diferencia entre utilidad
operativa y evites que ebit puede
incluir un poco de utilidad no operativa
que aquí no tengo pero este efectivo
pues podría estar generando un poco de
ganancias por inversiones en la bolsa o
algo así verdad se incluiría en el ebit
y no en la utilidad operativa pero
usualmente están muy cerca cuando
tenemos un negocio que no sea financiero
bueno entonces este de aquí es ebit si
queremos evitar hay que sumar
depreciación y amortización entonces
nada más consideraríamos hasta aquí esto
sería evita entonces tenemos que el adif
es de 35 mil si sumamos los 5.000 de
depreciación y amortización entonces
tendríamos que levita es de 40 mil
da 40 mil pesos ok entonces la pregunta
es por qué las personas se fijan en
evitar porque se usa evita en vez de
utilidad operativa y bueno la lógica es
que depreciación y amortización como lo
vimos en los vídeos de depreciación
amortizaciones personas simplemente
gastos que se repartieron en varios años
no necesariamente es efectivo que está
saliendo de la empresa entonces no sé
por ejemplo a lo mejor hace diez años
compre un equipo así súper caro un
equipo digamos de diez mil o de 100 mil
pesos que pues no se tenía una vida útil
de 20 años y entonces cada año descuento
a la vigésima parte o sea 5 mil pesos
pero ojo el efectivo ya salió hace mucho
tiempo entonces esta aplicación de
amortización en este periodo pues no es
efectivo que está saliendo de la empresa
en vídeos futuros vamos a ver cómo
determinamos realmente cuál es el
efectivo que sale pero bueno se
considera un gasto no en efectivo
entonces cuando te determinas evita y
está sumando impuestos intereses
depreciación y amortización entonces lo
que te queda es esencialmente cuánto
efectivo está generando la empresa se lo
pongo por aquí efectivo cuánto está
sacando a muchas personas les importa
porque esto es una indicación de uno la
capacidad de la empresa en su actividad
empresarial y no de otras cosas obtener
buen interés pagarlo pagar impuestos e
invertir en el negocio o bien otra forma
de pensarlo es que si ves el coeficiente
de valor empresarial entre evita para la
empresaria entre bien estás diciendo por
cada peso de efectivo que este negocio
saca supongamos que el negocio no está
reinvirtiendo ni comprando nuevo equipo
cuánto de ahí estoy pagando por la
empresa bueno una regla de cabecera y
que después voy a platicar más en otros
vídeos ahorita ya se me está acabando el
tiempo es que para una empresa muy
estable simple que no crezca y pues que
no se haga más pequeña entonces es un
valor empresarial de 55 veces el ebita
es justo pero lo que importa más
es que sucede en otras compañías de la
misma industria recuerda que todos estos
coeficientes son mejores como métricas
relativas en el futuro voy a ver algunas
cosas como un flujo de efectivo
descontado o bien el modelo de dividendo
descontado para hablar de cosas un poco
más absolutas pero recuerda que cuando
estás en el mercado libre cuando estás
decidiendo comprar unas cosas
implícitamente decides dejar de comprar
otras y de modo similar cuando vendes
unas cosas están decidiendo dejar de
vender otras es por esta razón que el
valor relativo podría ser importante
pero en fin espero que te sea de
utilidad esta información